men and women handle life differently
from dealing with a breakup to battling
an illness they are complete opposites
in the way they react the way they think
and the way they live if this is your
first time visiting our channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up because today
we're sharing 10 ways men and women
think differently
dealing with emotion when it comes to
dealing with emotions women are
definitely more expressive and in touch
with their feelings most women don't see
anything wrong with letting the tears
flow down no matter where they are guys
are a little more guarded when it comes
to expressing themselves they tend to
keep their emotions bottled up until
they're all alone and can let it open
private social interactions
most women are pros when it comes to
interacting with their friends and
complete strangers this is all thanks to
outdated gender roles when women were
taught to band together to accomplish a
task then on the other hand are more
like lone wolves most of them prefer to
work through out situations alone and
this greatly affects their ability to
interact with others to dealing with
pain women have been found to experience
pain more intensely than men estrogen
makes a woman's pain receptors more
sensitive especially during her
menstrual cycle women also recover from
pain faster they will seek out a doctor
more quickly and they don't allow them
to control their lives testosterone the
male hormone elevates men tolerance for
pain and allows them to withstand it for
much longer getting sick when a woman
gets sick she'll try her best to suck it
up so her illness doesn't affect her
daily activities but when a man gets
sick his entire life is in shambles most
men become absolutely miserable when
they're feeling under the weather and
they may be unable to get out of bed for
a few days there's actually a reason why
men and women react differently to
illness researchers believe the female
hormone estrogen slows down how fast a
virus multiplies leading to C or
symptoms in women and the part of the
brain that regulates body temperature is
much larger in men which could explain
why they suffer from higher fevers
asking for directions one of the most
stereotypical differences between men
and women is the way they ask for
directions when a guy gets lost he
relies on a spatial reasoning skills to
get him back on track men enjoy
discovering unknown areas and exploring
so getting lost really isn't a big deal
to them it gives them a chance to put on
their thinking caps and do
of problem-solving but for women they
create security and comfort so they'd
much rather stop and ask for directions
than to drive around aimlessly getting
undressed you've noticed the difference
between how men get undressed compared
to women right a man tends to reach
towards the back of his neck to yank a
shirt off by the collar while a woman
will lift her shirt by crossing her arms
over her chest and slowly pulling the
shirt over her head the reason behind
this could be the way in which some
shirts are constructed men shirts tend
to be roomier so it's easier for them to
tuck it off quickly while women have to
do things more gracefully because their
shirts are big tighter going through a
breakup after a bad breakup women take
time to process their emotions in order
to heal from their relationship coming
to an end this helps them move on and
move forward with mending their broken
hearts but men never really take the
time to recover from a breakup instead
of dealing with the sadness in the sense
of loss they try to move on as quickly
as possible but they tend to carry on
the baggage for years to come
remembering important things when a man
forgets his anniversary or his mother's
birthday he's not doing it on purpose
studies have shown that men and women
remember things differently and it all
has to do with their brain women have a
higher activity in their hippocampus a
major component of the brain stores
memories this is why women find it
easier to remember names places and
special events better than men risk
taking when a guy does something
completely thrilling it releases a large
dose of endorphins which trigger a happy
feeling throughout his entire body in
order to seal this pleasurable
experience over and over again you have
to keep taking risk women tend to play
it cool and approach life with caution
because they prefer safety this is why
men are more likely to take risks than
women intimacy men are much more visual
than women so they prefer to watch
naughty movies to get themselves in the
mood catching a glimpse of a woman's
body parts can make the guy's eyes pop
right out of his head
but women are a bit more complex when it
comes to sexual desire visual
stimulation doesn't always lead to
arousal a woman is more turned on by a
series of things including compatibility
with her partner emotions and essential
ambience if you agree with our list of
ways men and women think differently
leave us your comments down below and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up
you